Julian he's not Spanish he's actually
from France so you're from your French
not french-canadian right no your pure
French hundred US you know what made me
realize about the purpose of life is I
was going to bed every every nights and
thinking hey Salaam alaikum guys we're
here in Spain I'm with our brother here
and we are we're talking we were talking
about tell us Julian
you accepted Islam and before we get
into the meat and potatoes of your story
just real quick tell us what's the what
had you thinking what turned on the
thinking to have you reflect on what's
the purpose of life you know what made
me realize about the purpose of life is
I was going to bed every every night and
thinking of what's what's the whole
first about this life you know and I
thought I was not upon the hack I
thought if I died tomorrow
something very bad might happen to me
and I thought I can't keep keep living
my life without a real purpose but he's
given to me by God and that's what it
made me start to research in every type
of religion and and then I found that
there's no religion except his son that
tell you really what is your purpose so
that's why for me was a no-brainer
because we were there was no competition
you know we've been talking about that
you and I for the past few days is when
you look at other religions even if you
want to give them a chance to compete
with Islam they become very quickly
disqualified because at the end of the
day if a religion can't tell you what is
the purpose of your life what what do
you need it for you know and to be
honest that I always said I never wanted
to be a Muslim I never wanted to
you know practice Islam as a French I
thought it would be very hard but
because I wanted to be truthful to to my
Creator I had no choice to accept the
truth and and and and God tells us what
is the purpose is to worship in it and
in that it was a game changer for me
because now all I do in my life I focus
on that I tried to worship in the best
way I can and I know everything I start
doing will be a bonus because this is
the truth this is the true purpose we
need to fulfill you guys got that gem
that he had in his nature I mean a
person is not fulfilled in tins are
living purpose so you can be living for
money
what when that perishes you can't take
it with you when you go so he started to
reflect and that's the challenge now do
that if you're seeking purpose ask the
one who created you the owner of this
heavens of the creation of the heavens
and earth for guidance it guide me why
am I here and then open up a world
religions book start to look at the
introduction to these religions make
sure at the end you're sincere and then
also include Islam and then go ahead and
compare one to another and without a
doubt if you're sincere and you're
sincerely seeking the truth God Almighty
the Creator will guide you to that truth
which we believe is submission to his
will and that's Islam and the other
thing that he had mentioned it was
beautiful before we cut out is worship
and worship in Islam is loving
everything that the crater loves for you
to do that's good for you because now
you're living life according to your
desires or according to God's gameplan
and staying away from everything that
displeases the creator that's worship
he's living that stay tuned for more
here with our brother in Spain Harvin's
Valencia
you